i was always
a firm believer of whatever gift that
you have culturally you should be able
to make a life out of it
right now i'm working on dog collars
um beaded dog collars i haven't made
money since march
so i got to figure out other ways to
take care of myself and my family so
what better way to do it than to uh use
your own culture
as the kovit 19 pandemic stretches into
a second year new orleans a city hit
hard
early on in the pandemic and whose
economy is dependent on tourism
is trying to keep case numbers down
while also figuring out what tourism
looks like
in 2021 to better understand how the
city's economic landscape is impacting
those whose livelihoods are connected to
the tourism industry
i spoke to a few people to find out how
they're surviving financially and what's
at stake for their businesses and their
communities
how important is tourism to the new
orleans economy tourism is our major
economic driver mardi gras is a big big
deal
there is a tremendous amount of tax
revenue generated so
we are certainly missing that the
destination marketing organization in
the city
says the tourism industry was down 70 in
2020 compared to 2019
but jay banks a city council member says
safety is the priority over finances
i clearly understand the economics of
this but i'm also clearly understanding
the health concerns of it
and while i would like to be able to say
that we could do everything we do and
keep people safe
unfortunately we can't
before the pandemic how how many nights
a week were you playing
so i was playing like two three clubs a
week okay
before the pandemic bernard henry who
was born and raised in treme
a historically black neighborhood with
deep-rooted musical traditions
comes from an important musical family
in new orleans chester jones is my
grandfather
and i have uncle bennett he's the leader
of the tram abrams band
and i have my brother corey here
henry says the gigs he's able to get now
pay less than before the pandemic
recently he performed with treme brass
band outside dba
a popular frenchman street club that he
used to play inside of
we're playing in the dba we averaged
maybe like 250 dollars
with some tips you know but nowadays
we playing outside we're roughing it up
scrambling like a little 40 50
henry has been able to find work through
a mardi gras crew that has hired artists
and musicians as couriers
house float designers and more it's just
one example of how the city has come
together to help those who have taken
the biggest financial hit
hey guys how are you doing for alexis
graber
better known as trixie minx the
burlesque queen of new orleans her
business
trixie mink's productions was doing well
prior to the pandemic
that first quarter of 2020 was actually
like our highest grossing quarter
yet to date and we went
from that to literally it wasn't exactly
zero but like
i cried and almost a year into the
pandemic she's struggling to keep her
business afloat while also keeping her
employees working safely
i've tried everything i've done
everything from in-person shows to
virtual shows to zoom performances
in october she launched a weekly virtual
show at dba on frenchman street
all those shows went so smoothly but the
problem was is that
we didn't make money and if anything we
lost money and that
quarter i say this a lot it felt like
a sucker punch and a knife twist and a
kick while you were down
after a reset she scaled back the shows
at dva to once a month
i was super excited about this honestly
thank you guys for making my weekend
the hardest choice i had to make was
realizing we had to do
less to be able to save the business and
it seems counterintuitive but
in doing shows doing them safely and
doing them regularly
actually lost the company more money
well this is a live music street
first and foremost that's what keeps it
going and
unless we all open
it doesn't really do much good another
business owner who found that being open
was actually causing her to lose more
money
is sophie lee lowry the owner of three
muses a restaurant and jazz club on
frenchman street
regular friday night you can't even get
a table or sit at the bar
but the pandemic forced the restaurant
to close down in march until they were
able to get a ppp grant
i had used my savings i brought money
from family
exhausted every avenue i had until
finally the money came in she tried to
reopen for takeout and delivery but
without the street's regular foot
traffic
she found it wasn't sustainable can you
talk a little bit about how much
you're still paying to keep this place
dormant
back in march april may not only did we
have the rent and the utilities
we still had purveyors that we owed so
our income stopped march 15th but our
bills kept coming in
it was somewhere around 30 thousand
dollars a month
just operating costs on a shuttered
business
thankfully that's gone down as our bills
were paid so now i would say it's around
fifteen thousand dollars for a closed
business
yes with zero revenue coming in
right her application for a second round
of ppp was denied
but she's reapplied with additional
documentation and she's holding off on
reopening
until she gets funding and the covet 19
outlook improves
[Music]
for many in new orleans the pandemic
isn't just a threat to their health or
their bank accounts
it's also a threat to their cultural
traditions you know
culture doesn't get preserved for free
shakazulu is the big chief of the golden
feather hunters a masking indian tribe
in new orleans
he has a few businesses related to his
culture like a gallery a stage
performance and a feather supply company
on the weekends he teaches an african
stilt dancing class in his community
my life is you know not just a cultural
keeper this is what i do for a living
the pandemic ground his work to a halt
but for zulu
the questions are bigger than when he
will be able to resume those projects
i think this pandemic exposed what's
been going on for
since the beginning he says the pandemic
has highlighted long-term inequality
how dollars brought into new orleans by
tourists don't always find their way
back to the culture bearers who attract
many of those visitors to the city
outcome is always about us but when it
comes to economics
it's without us
[Music]
the pandemic may possibly bring
attention to that
because for once everybody is shut down
you know nobody is open so now
what's going to bring the tourism back